Precomputing, all early
standards were for data.
Physicians would use ICD,
a classification of diseases,
in their notes.
The clinical laboratory would have
a classification for their tests.
And the pharmacy would
have a classification for
the medications they dispense.
As computers came into use in hospitals,
the various departments needed to share
information, but were using their
own specialized computer systems.
This led to early messaging standards.
These meant a physician could order
a lab test or medication at the nurse's
station, and that order could be routed
electronically to the appropriate
department to do the test or
send the medication.
The next evolution was standards for
clinical documents.
A message might typically be
an order for a lab test or
medication, but what if you want
a complete summary of a patient's care
to send to the patient's physician once
they're discharged from the hospital?
This is the role of document standards.
More recently, as computers have become
more powerful, standards have been
evolving to represent clinical
workflows and processes.
These have often been
targeted at hospitals, but
have proven to be hard to develop and
implement.
If this could be overcome, they could,
at least in theory, lead to a reduction
in unnecessary variations in
the way patients are cared for.